مزيج من المخدرات القاتلة ينتشر
عبر الولايات المتحدة في جميع الولايات الخمسين تقريبًا،
الآن فيرنوكا مع الزيلازين مما يترك بعض
المستخدمين خائفين وجرحى، لقد أزالوا
سبعة أرطال من اللحم ولترًا ونصف
بعد أن
كان مفتوحًا لمدة 21 شهرًا، هذا هو مدى
فظاعة
جسدك  شفاء للمرة الأولى منذ
إقرار قانون عام 2018 الذي يسمح لها بذلك. إن
اتخاذ إدارة بايدن
خطوة غير مسبوقة
بالإعلان رسميًا عن مادة وتهديد ناشئ،
يعني أن بعضًا من طلب ميزانية
الأدوية الذي قدمه الرئيس بايدن إلى الكونجرس والذي يزيد عن 46 مليار دولار
يمكن شفاؤه
يمكن أن تساعد الأموال المستخدمة للاستجابة في دفع تكاليف
اختبار المخدرات، وجمع البيانات
وتطوير العلاجات، ونحن نرسل
رسالة واضحة إلى المنتجين
والمتاجرين بالزالازين والفنتانيل غير
المشروعين بأننا
سنرد بشكل أسرع في المعركة الشاقة
والمخدرات المتغيرة باستمرار.  لقد تغير المشهد الطبيعي لكلا
النوعين من المخدرات من المواد
العضوية في الغالب إلى
المواد الاصطناعية في الغالب، ولكن الطريقة التي يتم بها شراء
وبيع المخدرات تغيرت أيضًا الآن، فكل ما
تحتاجه هو هاتف في راحة
يدك وتطبيق الوسائط الاجتماعية